[音楽]
OG
こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんはUF
キャッチャーというものをご存知でしょう
かゲームセンターとかにあるなんか
ぬいぐるみを取ったりとかフィギュアを
取ったりだとかいろんな景品を100円を
入れたり200円入れたりしてアメでその
景品を取るUFキャッチャーってものが
あるんですけれど
も私見つけてしまいました現金のUF
キャッチャー
自分で作りました自分で作ってしまいまし
たなんかUFキャッチャーいろんな景品と
かあるんですけれども1番楽しいのって
きっと現金だと思うんですよというわけで
今回こちらに1万
札3億円分準備しまし
た3億円すごくないすかもう見た目
が
バカなんでしょうか僕バカみたいなUF
キャッチャーですよ多分これはねわから
ないですけど世界で1番高いUF
キャッチャーなのではないかと思いたいと
いうわけで早速現金3億円のUFO
キャッチャーやってみたいと思いますでは
行こう衝撃的な映像ですが早速ちょっと
3億のUFキャツ見ていきたいと思い
ますすごいな基本的にね1万がバラバラと
置いてある感じにはなってるんですけども
たまにこう
いう100万円がありますはいというわけ
で早速3億円のUFキャッチャー遊んでみ
たいと思いますまこれジバだから俺がやっ
たところでなんだよね見てみたいどれ
ぐらいの強さかどれぐらい取れるのかマジ
で気になるのでやってみたいと思いますえ
100円でワン
プレイ1枚取れれば9900プラスやりと
だよねこんなの取れるかどうかがポイント
なんですよねやります行き
ますいやもう狙うわマジでもうちょ
とりあえず最初は雑にやってみ
ましょうこれぐらいかな
行けどうでしょうどうでしょうどう
でしょうえそれいけるんじゃないいける
か
うわ滑ったっぽいな滑ったっぽくなかっ
たそそんな34回もカチカチするんださ
タバ狙いすぎた多分今ね範囲としてはサタ
狙ってたからだと思うんですよほと細かい
とこ狙ってみようさタバじゃないところ
狙っていきたい
[音楽]
来いどう
だ
ストップ
あ取れれれれれれ取れてる行けけけけ
[音楽]
行け取れまし
た2万円ゲットです俺もうちょい取れそう
な気がすんだよなちょっともう1回やって
み
[音楽]
ますここでもうUFキツはうまくなって
おく
とうんそそこら辺札束じゃなくて札束の奥
のその1万円がたくさん詰まってるところ
がっといき
たいどう
でしょうあマジ
かだめかこれ多分思ったより難しいぞもう
1回さた狙っていいやっぱ音が欲しい
でしょ100万円これを手にしないと
始まらないよなるからなこれですね多分
これなら多分いけるはず
だやばいかよしよよし行ってる行ってる奥
まで行ってるのが大事
ですすごく
ね待って待ってこれ結構来てる
[音楽]
けどすごくね
今さつは無理だったけどめちゃくちゃお
撮影に入った
[音楽]
12345678901
11万円やば次はアームの力100%で
マックスの力でやってみたいと思い
ますじゃ早速やってみたいと思います行く
よ本気で狙うからね行きますもう狙いはね
本当にこの
100万円100万円狙えたらいいんです
けど
ね強欲にねダブルでいくっていうどう
でしょう来い
[音楽]
どうどうこれダブルダブル狙ないで
よ200万コイン200万
こい
行けその
まま行け行け行け行け
[音楽]
行け見て見て見
てえぐ
[音楽]
やべえ見
て100万円ゲット
ていいんこれでちょっと優しすいます
ちょっと優しいねちょっと難度調整しよう
か今アームのレベルマックスになってるん
ですけども50%ぐらいでちょっとやって
み
ます次は俺ちょっとやってみたかったこと
があるんですけれども
さたご覧くださいの殺をすごい積み重ねて
みましたこれ果たして取れるかどうかだよ
ねどうなるんだろうちょっとやってみます
行き
ますほいどう来
てるこれ割とちゃんと真ん中取りたいよ
ねはいどうどうどうどうどうこれぐらいで
いいんじゃないかな
行けどうなるどうなる
[音楽]
くそちょっと練習しておきたいな何回か
やりますこれ手前とか狙ってみたいよね
これでいいんじゃないか
などう
[音楽]
でしょう
行けほほほほほえええええ
[音楽]
え
えっと
1234567891011121314151617181920
[音楽]
ちゃって落ちないっていうのもこのUF
キャッチャーの罠の1つだなああ
楽しい
けど自分のお金だからつまらないこれさ俺
自分のお金で自分でやるんじゃなくて誰か
のお金でやるからこそこういうUF
キャッチャー本当にもらえる突然どうした
突然動き出しちゃったけど大丈夫かこれ
UFOキャッチャーてそのやって実際に
もらえるから嬉しいのであって俺これ自分
のお金でやってるからなんかそのたくさん
お金取れてもあのそんな嬉しくないすよ
これはきっとですね僕のお金を誰かにやら
せるからこそ面白いんですよというわけで
2023年今年まはめ社長を特に支えて
くれた男いますやらせてあげ
ましょうただねあのさすがにねそんな甘い
世界じゃないので運が良ければたくさん
取れるけどもちろんちゃんとゲームとして
やりたいのでちょっと設定ちゃんとしよう
ちょうどいいうまくいけばめっちゃお金
ゲットできるし失敗したらあんまりお金
もらえないみたいなちょうどいい設定に
ちょっと1回頑張って設定しますパワー0
です0とかあるんだねUFキャットの設定
で0で果たしてどれぐらい取れるの
か
えこれ0だよね0だったよねえやばパワー
0でも3万円ぐらい取れるんだけど意外と
何でもいいのかうん優しいっすね優しいね
ゼロでささ束取れるかやってみてよおお
願いします行きます
パワーゼロで殺サバが取れるかどうかな
そう簡単に100万円なんてあげれない
からなそうですよね行き
[音楽]
ますいいねあるかあるある
かこれ一番弱い力よ
[音楽]
すごええいいの絶対取れちゃうじゃん玉
だけちょっとじきたい本当に
うんはいどうでしょうあまさすがにね
さすがに無理か
無理これにしよっかさすがにでもちょっと
チャンス上げたいからもうちょい強めに
やっとくか
[音楽]
おはいというわけで早速はみ社長からの
年末特大ビッグボーナス3億円U
キャッチャー今年のはじめ社長の周りの中
のMVPにやらせたいと思いますやみ
[音楽]
ましょう何これ
金だすげえすげえすげえすげえすげええ
本物
これ大かおびっくりしたバさんお疲れ様
です
えバさん今年自お疲れ様でしたお疲れ様
でし
たさオにホキャちゃんワンプレイ
プレゼントですいやマジでこれ本物これさ
本物ですおマジでえこれガってやって取っ
たやつはゲットゲットですうおすごマジで
大今年本当よく頑張ってくれると思うんで
あの家の周りとかねはいうちのあのあれ
ですボーナスですあ
好き好きうわこれこんなに緊張する
クレインゲームないよこれやばいよこれ
やばいよちなみに設定はちゃんと取れるか
取れないか絶妙なところになってますあ
もうそう調整してあるはい何回か思考して
うわ悪質なゲームセンターみたいな設定に
はなってないはいなるほどなるほどいや
マジで狙い目絶対タバなんだよね束は
でかいね束を狙うしかないただ束は結構む
ずそうではありましたなるほどねでもどせ
だったらね大金欲しいからタバ行きます
大丈夫です
か
うわただ束狙いに行って他の札えたりも
するからいいチャンス狙っては全然いいと
思はいはいはい狙います行きますさんはい
1回だけですよねはいあすごい緊張する
すごいやばい手が
すごいよし行きます行って
ください
始まったはいはいはいはいはいはいあの2
束ねニコの束2の束やっぱこれ人にやら
せるのが面白な自分でやっててもさ自分の
お金だから全然盛り上がんなかったって
いう絶対取る行き
ますはいはいはいはいはいはいお願いし
ますこれ行けるかうわちょっと多くなった
気がする頼むお願いあ待って全然ダメかも
しれない全然ダメかもしれないこれはい
掴んて頑張って
あってだ
おい
[音楽]
くそ
ちょっとかわいそうなのでもう1回させて
あげますか本当ですかもう1うざさ難し
そうだったからな手堅いとこになってみ
そうだねちょっとさは諦めますさ
はいおい負けちゃったりしちゃうかおい
おいおおいおいおおい最高かよおい
素晴らしい素晴らしいあもう見えました
これでもうねガットガットもうさは諦め
ますスタバはすいませんもう1回だけはい
も大丈夫マジラストチャンスラスチャンス
オよしよしよし行きます慎重にねそこの束
を狙いすぎると本当にやばいからね本当
に
はいここ
です行ったべこれ行ったべこれ行った
べちょ確ガチボーナスになりますこれま
ガチガチでガチボーナスいいいい
いい
おジてマジで早くれに落ちてれに落ちて
マジかえ本当
ねおいおいおい
おいりまし語りましょマジ
でマジですいマジで
1234567891011121314151617181920
[音楽]
マジかマジでこれはおめでとうございます
めでとうございますいやでも本当やっぱ家
の管理とか大変な中あスタッフも増えた中
実は初めとにたくさんスタッフがいるん
ですけどそうですね本頑張ってくれたので
ささにご褒ありがとうございますではない
ですけど本当に大きなおめでとうござい
ましありがとうござい
ますもう1回いやマジで喜んでたね君本当
今年俺一番頑張ってたと思うんでよく
頑張りましたそしてもう1人
あの最近ね今年もコラボできないという
ことでやっぱ身内というか周りにいる人と
しか動画撮れなかったから畑のみんなとか
いろんな人にお世話になったんですけども
特にお世話になった後輩サあいつもね今年
なんかすごい仲良くしてくれたのでご褒美
というかMVPということで彼にも3億円
フキャッチャー調させたいと思い
ますいやちょっと待って
くださいはじめさんいつもサーベにご飯
奢ったりしてるじゃないですかまそうね
ちょっとそれは甘やかしすぎじゃないです
かああ確かにほぼご飯出してるからそう
ですよすごいですよ食品ちょっとやりすぎ
じゃないです
かいやま年末なので甘えさせていいんじゃ
ないです
かさすがにね年末なのでいや本当はみんな
にやらせてあげたいんですけどもちょっと
本当にギュっとMVPだけに今回これやら
せたいと思ってますはいいやちょっと
甘やかしすぎだ
ないいんですたまにはそしてサーベはなん
と特別にご覧ください
[音楽]
こちらこれ何千あるんだえ100多分
3000万ぐらいかな3000万タワ準備
しまし
たこれやばくないこれもうすごいぞ
せっかくだからパワーもマックスでいいん
じゃない
優しいあの最大出力でやらせあけたいと
思いますこれなら多分結構取れると思うん
だよな早速後輩サーベ読みたいと思い
ます
うわや
ばや
ば財布持ってないわささん疲れですお疲れ
様ですお疲れ様ですはい何ですかこれサー
ははいよく頑張ってくれたのでね褒に
はいワンプレやらせていきますありがとう
ございます取ったのもらえるもりますやり
ます食べたどうぞワンプレだけだからワン
プレー入ってえぐこれもやるしかないよ
やるしかないっすよね絶対このタワー狙っ
た方がいいじゃん100%そうだよねこれ
は狙いますよさあ見してください行きます
もうそんな始めていいのかもう始めちゃっ
大丈夫かいもうもう行きますもう行きます
大丈夫か大丈夫か大丈夫本当頼む1発だけ
だから本当にき
ます大丈夫かいや結構真ん中だと思う
けど来いやる
かこっから
行け
くそ
えぐさべはいかわいそうなのではいもう1
回どうぞありがとうございますちょ難し
すぎたね難しいっすねじってやったから
難しいからなはい次もこれでどうあこれ
なら結構いいんじゃないですかえでも
ちょっと優しいなどうサこれいいよどう
これでいや余裕でしょこれならいける
でしょ行けますよしてくれや行きますね
行きます
はいどうでしょういいんじゃね
結構ここでしょういいんじゃないあかこれ
はあ結構
真ん中来たぞ
け
刺されお
あくそべ見てみやばすぎ
ごめんごめんなあの結構本当にお金は
たくさんあるんですけど3北は準備でき
なかったダミはたくさんあるんですけども
やっぱ中にはねあ本物もあるんですかガチ
だちゃんと本物もあるのではいもう本当に
ラストチャンス分かりましたこっからは
もう本物しかないっす見て
くださいはい本物ですねじゃもうここに
置きますもうこれで
どうバーンて置きましたもうよし準備でき
ましたさんよっしゃお願いしますこれどう
すか最高ですこれは取れますよよし行こう
ぜお願いします行きますよ1回もう本当
ラストだからラストチャンスまずでもにし
ます
行けずは真ん中おおいいじゃないですか
中心行きますはい頑張れどう
でしょう行けおええあるあるある
あるある
かおいおいおいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばい
わおいばいやばいじゃん破れちゃってる
けど
やばいないないこれ100万100万
200万200万300はい300万
ゲットおめでとうやっ
た夢
[音楽]
かH